What are you doing in Paris?
I'll take it.
This too.
It's five hundred for the belt and two thousands for each bag.
Great.
I'm a personal shopper.
Here's a very high-profile.
Thank you.
She can't do normal things.
So, I assist her.
You have nothing better to do besides dress Keira?
I'm waiting.
What are you waiting for?
My twin brother,died here
It's been 95 days.
We made this oath.
Whoever died first will send the other a sign.
From the afterlife.
Has that always been there?
Louis.
Are you here?
I had a sign.
Are you sure?
There was a presence.
Do you think Louis is here?
I don't know.
Keira?
I'm just gonna drop these bags for you, okay?
Hey.
Keira was murdered.
What were you doing at her place?
Why are you asking?
I'm lost.
I can't tell whether or not i'm going crazy.
Louis is that you?
Or is it just me?